bien des gens se trouvent surtout que
robert yang a codé qui sont vraiment
érotique échoue elle s'est battue
commence tout de suite avec stick shift
ça joue déjà le but du jeu est de faire
plaisir à une voiture gay tue pas quoi
dire après un indice à 2 tu peux rien
dire aux démarre la voiture voilà on
roule et on va pouvoir lui faire plaisir
en bougeant sa main seuls les enfants de
quitter vraiment retourné voir des tutos
adibou parce que là c'est dérangeant et
plus on va vite plus la voiture accélère
et plus quoi aussi accident way
a encore une panne mais qu'est-ce qui se
passe
ben moi en voiture il faut que je fasse
ça pour qu'elle accélère mais je la
revois immédiatement contre 1 grecque
m'a bien aucun problème
pourquoi avec armes qu'elles soient en
fait faut passer les vitesses d'accord
ok j'avais pas vu là on va mettre la
troisième à merde j'ai calé jeu [ __ ]
attend hop là haut le chief ojo mais
dans le blanc énorme et la troisième
attention pas si je me sers le baladeur
faire plaisir des voitures et vous allez
ça existe et mécano fils ou je sais pas
quoi
on passe en 4e rang regarde et attend
d'autres peintres a carrément de jouir
en fait on fait plaisir à semer clope à
la voiture quoi regarder le bon goût de
se remettre la cinquième
alors là ça va être quoi
il ya police pourquoi les filles
viennent dans cette histoire je
comprends pas la focus pasqua j'envoie
des bisous mais ça n'a aucun choix ce
pour quoi j'avais plein de bisous hangar
et ils ont défoncé en fait c'est la fin
et plus j'en fais des bisous puis me
retiennent en otage césaire si je fais
un bisou sur la joue dernier deux
policiers ils ne retiendront huit
semaines elle est sauvage pour michelin
attendait aussi une fin alternative
c'est belle blague en plus à temps mais
moi je pense que je suis bloqué là je
peux plus jouer pendant 11h47 a toujours
instable mais non mais non
on est maintenant sur reims et et répété
celui-là il est extrêmement érotique
parce qu il s agit pas de voiture un ok
donc on est sous la douche quand il ya
des hommes sont en train d'entrer aux
mondiaux donc leur parle coach ascquois
a tancé le malaise qui est ce beauf non
mais faut qu'on m'explique la salut mec
à temps il a d'autres femmes quoi peau
qui s mais arrête
j'ai besoin d'aidé avec mon dos oh non
non c'est tellement lui à la coupole
plus humiliant de ma vie en plus j'ai le
poignet cassé le rebelle 6-1 bachiri mon
gars tu es toi tiens je frotte fort
comme sur un char à lantin il ralentit
aux jeux permanents à temps immonot
huguenote il a hélas est ce qu'il a
apprécié tu as douanes fait mon pote à
temps mais dis pas ça ne vous dit pas
les choses comme ça ses biceps
arrête de gémir [ __ ] s'est achevée sur
la côte j'en ai marre du bras il va
mongole et il va mongole et après bon
mec comme ça t'en gueule tu as peur tu
sais pas ce qui va te faire donc aller
c'est tout ou rien mais tais toi c'est
trop mou attend faut savoir d'ailleurs
je suis trop fort et je suis trop vous
si vous faire sexuelle j'ai vu mieux mon
gars mais arrête de me juger
c'est quoi la suite c'est le mac où il
frotte pas été dur au lait d'été avec
grand plaisir tient le tt le tt cette
vidéo pour une tournure totalement
inattendu a les ouvrages les tétées d'un
autre mec ma vie c'est de la merde à
frost et et du calme à temps mais qu'il
est pire exigeant demandé truc trop
bizarre et en plus il est hyper
exigeants quoi quoi mais il a plus aucun
respect ats contredit vient de demander
de continuer de faire l'auteur the way
plus fort comme ça vas-y plus dans le
temps mais faut savoir ça tourne pas
rond chez toi non mais attends jan
bucquoy
non mais j'en peux plus quoi une extrême
mais peut-être qu'à chaque fois on
pourrait faire plus bas temps mais ça
m'intéresse pas du tout adacore cette
fois je me douche j'allais me rejoint
alors je suis seul on me fait passer
frère s'il vous plaît mais non mais
c'est une blague
faux j'attends de vote cet arrêté mais
je vais me buter
oh
[Musique]
allez cette fois on s'applique on fait
ça correctement voyage tu es le seul qui
me comprennent oh je ressens une sorte
de lien entre nous ah ben pas moi désolé
à les essais je sais quoi c'est lui je
sais que je peux faire confiance on a
réussi j'ai besoin de l'affection sur
mon uchi aura quel jantes et de mère
bordel pourquoi la lutte avec calme et
beau bordel
ces douches publiques arrêté à michel
sais quoi du coup la deuxième fin de ce
jeu là on va voir ça o o alors alors il
se passe quoi cette fois à sakho tiéné
pas les flics
ok en gros tu veux trop plaisir [ __ ]
alors un an
oui bon mais les gens s'énervent cette
vidéo sur les deux mots jeux que robert
mugabe sorties fades
il en a sorti d'autres aussi mais ces
deux là sont vraiment exceptionnelles on
est en vue de présenter à son petit
frère se passe de 9 plus c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo comme
youtube et bien sûr vous très bientôt
dans une prochaine
allez on fait un petit café à bientôt tu
as tout le monde pis
[Musique]